and our shutout tonight for the federal
court reporter at the Detroit News who
for the last two years has been breaking
some very big stories about one of this
country's most significant labor unions
the United Auto Workers the UAW Detroit
is a Union town and the annual Labor Day
Parade is a big event but the news
coverage this year was driven by the
revelation that the city's most powerful
union leader Gary Jones the President of
the United Auto Workers the UAW is the
subject of an FBI investigation of
alleged corruption a story broken by
Robert Snell the Detroit News there were
protesters union workers protesting you
know decrying the corrupt the reports of
corruption that have come out of federal
court Gary Jones marched for part of the
parade declined comment to reporters on
the scene and left before the parade was
finished Snell who covers the federal
courts for the Detroit News first
started working on the UAW corruption
story some two years ago there's a lot
of outrage in some circles the the the
workers fear that this is confirmation
of what they've suspected that some UAW
leaders might just be out for themselves
and not for the average blue-collar
worker so far nine people have been
convicted the latest this week in
federal court in Detroit the Union has
sought to portray the convictions as not
that significant I mean I think we're
fairly well sourced with you know people
close to the investigation and there
hasn't been a challenging of any of the
facts what what they have tried to focus
reporters on is that this is merely a
few bad apples who have been charged and
convicted and that this doesn't
represent a broader crisis for the UAW
but this past week Snell and his
colleagues briana novo and ian
Thibodeaux broke the story that the
union president himself
Jones was part of the investigation
with exclusive coverage of an FBI raid
on Jones's home during the search the
investigators had left the garage door
open at Gary Jones home and one of the
neighbors across the street who was
watching this dramatic federal search
unfold grabbed his binoculars and could
see agents in the garage with the open
garage door counting what this neighbor
described as watts of cash really sort
of a dramatic description of what was
unfolding on the scene today federal
agents descended on the homes of some
top officials with one of the nation's
largest unions the raid on the home of
the UAW president was picked up by news
organizations across the country who had
pretty much ignored the story until now
today FBI special agents searching
inside the Canton Michigan home of UAW
president Gary Jones it's been somewhat
of a lonely beats once we broke the news
that the FBI and IRS and labor
department were you know investigating
and searching multiple locations around
the country the the coverage mushroomed
you know you started to see the
financial wires and pretty much every
major newspaper Wall Street Journal
start to weigh in and cover the
developments from last week the
allegations are reminiscent of the
blatant corruption at the Teamsters
Union something I covered in my early
days as an NBC News correspondent except
now there are a lot fewer reporters
assigned to cover such stories it's
tough in the newspaper industry with you
know fewer resources but thankfully my
editors have stayed committed to the
story for over two years
so it's it's a matter of you know what
we're gonna devote resources to and this
is like you said a union town it's a big
story in Detroit and we've been staying
on top of it for two years plus and
there's more to come you think for sure
definitely
in a statement the UAW says the union
and as president Gary Jones have always
fully cooperated with the government
investigation and suggests what it calls
profit laden auto companies stand to
benefit from media leaks false
assumptions and political grandstanding
but from what we can see
none of that would apply to Rob Snell
and the Detroit News now that's our
program for tonight thanks so much for
joining us we'll see you back here again
and next week